oh hey guys eylem put Animal Crossing
down how you doing I hope you're all
doing as well as can be I'm not gonna
see great because I know times it's so
freakin weird right now but I hope that
you're at least staying as safe as you
can be I think we're all a little bit
insane right now and that's okay if
you're insane as well we'll get through
this together and one of the ways that
I'm gonna get through this is by playing
Animal Crossing and Resident Evil that's
out now and I have live streams the very
first game play for you and now I'm
reading it enjoy my let's play of
Resident Evil three remake just to
clarify it's definitely for
entertainment purposes please do not
expect me to be the best game play
person ever but you know it's all a bit
of fun here I will be live-streaming way
more of this for you in the future so
make sure that you follow me on Twitter
on Instagram and join the disco group
down in the description below to find
out when I'll be streaming next enjoy
- Burcu CDC is quarantine the lower
Midwestern this is a little bit too
close to home ready and equipment
honesty integrity these are the core
values that create the foundation from
it's this foundation it will continue to
build a brighter future for all of
Matt's the face of evil right then
Oh God
yeah
they transport in the nemesis
[Music]
I don't know why but I feel ready
nervous well
no this game looks cool already oh sorry
sorry sorry you guys hate when I do this
I've noticed from my comments you guys
hate it when I start to get all and
leave the needs and last two passes that
I'm just trying to get a good
[Music]
can I not crouch
because the window is cold outside
unnerving combats
cool cool little collection posters
right there
so I never well that's a lie I did play
visit evil 3 a long time ago this is my
friend it was her game and we used to
like have sleepovers and play Resident
Evil together so I don't know I don't
remember much apart from how nemesis
comes you have those little choice
choice bits it's pretty oh love look who
is what's her name again
did they stop flapping because I went
near them
oh I like that
Oh what like that
how is the audio ratios or all sound
good guys moons donuts hell yeah oh I
want donuts
it's at my bathroom
Oh me she looks damn good she was great
I might want to turn up Oh No
I've got no speed
she dream in
okay that was a dream that was very cool
first month of my life September hmm
this game is very lasers every night are
we back in back in our apartment now
escape was she escaping - oh it's just
going they'll picture a dog on her table
it's so cute
you have got extremely bad signal girl
while these pills
too many pills
anything outside that we can see
your support it's already been two
months since the mess with umbrella wait
I didn't audio is perfect great thanks
believe me no guys then oh yeah two
months since we mess with umbrella
thanks the suspension investigations
haven't progressed exactly as I'd hoped
perhaps this written record of what I've
found will prove to be my final duties
of stars officer I can only hope that it
helps lead to the truth those infected
by the virus seem to be calm literal
zombies mutro Antares be calm it appears
to be communicable via several different
avenues outlined below
- affected individual allowing the mixed
mixing of bodily fluids contact with
crows which have eaten infected - carry
on I was literally thinking that today
sorry to just interrupt that Resident
Evil storyline but I've really hoped
that birds can't contract a corona virus
because they've been really sad because
I think I think dogs are definitely
means them anyway to it due to the
strength of the virus airborne infection
cannot be discounted it should be noted
that those who survived the incidents
have not yet developed symptoms it's
unclear whether this is because the
virus has a long incubation period or
because we happen to be resistant to the
infection we ought to remain vigilant
even after this investigation period it
ends as of me aside from my minor
difficulty sleeping I seem to be in fine
shape oh so she actually has got the
virus but she hasn't
hasn't got any symptoms from it
interesting
Pharmaceuticals company in this true
leader in market share focuses on
military weapons development while
maintaining cover us a pharmacist or
pharmaceutical company also secretly
developing bioweapons t-virus
outbreak at Arklay mountains research
facility predicted predicated predicted
the mansion incident oh the mansion
incident
okay so the mayor's in on it and I know
all this stuff so I'm probably a big big
target
we won't we go
what's this
you've got me pinned down at home guys
across the street are watching me from
the window 24/7 yep see I'm a target are
the irons men umbrellas I don't know and
there's no real difference anyway I know
what they're trying to do they want to
wear me down Tom immune to compliance
and it's working I'm barely eating
barely sleeping I'm going crazy I feel
like the Living Dead guys across the
street I'm just I'm gonna check the
windows but I won't let them win I have
to get out of the city and find a way to
make them accountable they'll send
someone to silence me of course if you
hear that I've been killed or whatever
it is they do to people like me you must
pick up the investigation where you left
off I've enclosed my files and I'll tell
you everything you need to know as long
as this package isn't intercepted I'll
be moving out tonight five days which we
love
Wow oh I wanted to see at least one
person watching me
well this she reacts to the sirens I
guess
sure you're back into the bathroom Oh
hey hotshot how you holding up still
can't believe i unsuspended you it's
such [ __ ] he oughta pin a medal on
you for making you house hall bath in
july of course you're gonna be pokey or
you're going to poke around and ask
questions about it about it I hope
you're not mad at me for ask for keeping
my head down everything's been happening
so flat stars was the prior to the force
when the chief about disbanded us out of
nowhere I thought for sure I was gonna
lose my job
word has it you're planning to leave
Raccoon City I figured you wouldn't take
the suspense in lying down just promise
to watch your back and brother won't sit
by while you try to dismantle their
business
take care Jail Brad Vickers PS had to
see this message the pizza guy to avoid
detection enjoyed the extra punch make a
meat supreme wow that's nice it looks
like she did enjoy it along with some
soup and I have cold cold pizza for
breakfast which is always nice cool I
got some milk
it is actually my tap is actually on
she's really bad for wasting water
they go see you're okay you're not a
zombie
apparently Oh apparently the audio is a
little bit I'm going to turn it up just
a tad let me know if you need it turned
up anymore for you
all right I'm coming
[Music]
just a sec
hello Joe
are you okay Brad is that you listen
you've gotta get out of there what are
you talking about I don't have time to
explain you gotta get out of there right
now
all right let me grab my
well that was a quick introduction Jesus
he's a mummy
yeah he'll like don't even waste your
bullets just me yeah that's good night
that's gonna hold him down just pass
through your wall
[Music]
and I might buy you like two seconds
guys go what is happening you guys see
the window
[Music]
this is basically it so quickly
[Music]
this is what I don't like about now take
out his whatever the hell that is
where is he lassen and just come get ya
well that made us move fast come on
let's go
was that her oh I don't know I'm not
going back up there now okay Oh
oh my god this guy
I wonder if I could have died throughout
all of that I don't think so
with the [ __ ] deeds
wait if I go towards the wall or she
just automatically touch it oh hey is
that bill oh it's Brad
I mean I'm Jill who thing's Brad okay
time to find out right now it's got a
hard-on to the only two stars left in
town you and me I'm not sticking around
just look around you
the longer we wait the more screwed
wheel but I never finished my beat one
fucked-up thing always leads to another
cigar click on steroids
pretty
nobody cares why did he go I don't know
did we waste all of our on our nemesis
I hope not I'm just going show them Oh
but I thought Jill was already infected
and that's what she was having those
nightmares so well Nami Brad why did I
keep putting
[ __ ] oh that would have been cool of him
as Brad but I guess that was - that was
too quick okay this is how I use PC they
said you will aim better they Peck I'm
out of ammo now what do I do
Oh
[Music]
well that's not safe these are odd okay
whatever you say why
anything around here for me I do need
some ammo because I messed up just now
sir what's your nice if I could find
some ammo
oh never mind it don't need you I got my
own
okay girl let's come to this oh this is
too good
it means he's already close to throw
peck penny tonight
[ __ ] this don't come out please
I think we're okay
anything around here for me to pick up
I'm gonna be looking at beware because I
really don't want to miss any ammo
because I will need every little piece
that I can get
trust in there
nope let's know I'm around here
[Music]
[Music]
let's run around and oh my god quick
[Applause]
remember the needs no montez's do not
watch the demo Denise I don't think the
knees work in resident evil 3 and all
the comments are like
[Music]
weren't you scared I will be but right
now some ways zombies ain't nothing
I mean yeah sure I might be nearly dead
okay he's already dead [ __ ]
okay hold it hold it hold it
where's the airbag oh my gosh
now you're super nearly dead
Oh No took off it's mummification casing
how are we gonna get out of this
[Music]
I'm seen let's get you someplace safe
well he won't for umbrella
I think we're in the clear
hope so we've been bringing my guys have
converted some subway cars into a
shelter safe I'm fine
personal space okay I get it
social distancing oh come on just a
[ __ ] to close this sorry we're gonna
have to go around my weight like it
each it's no zombie knows what it wants
it won't stop till gets it don't you
like that in a man
no thing what he's all yours
I promise you're in good hands I'm with
the Umbrella biohazard countermeasures
hmm yes yes sure
are you kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me yeah the ones who caused all
whoa whoa what are you talking about you
don't have to trust me but I'm going to
the show this way
I was already here dawna bytes so tasty
they might go extinct all of these
advertisements oh that's [ __ ] creepy
a spy on Skull stalker oh it's a
terminator and that looks a little bit
like alien adrift in space huh
interesting
I like this attention to detail oh
that's Stephanie alien reference oh no
it's a tyrant of the deep hell squid oh
it's like Cthulhu vibes we have a asto
crunch freak cinema
comic books
I really want to buy Harleen I keep
putting it in my Amazon basket and
they're not buying it captain it's fine
only they could use our help
Carlos you didn't even think the worst
fine young lady your name PG is an elite
operative of I repeat these special
tactics and Rescue Service
her name is something Valentine well at
least you no harm a bit nice to meet you
Jill
I am you BCS platoon leader Michael
Victor my team was sent here to rescue
civilians oh great how's that going for
you
this city is completely cut off isolated
most of the hundred thousand civilians
will wind up that correction undead my
platoon has suffered serious losses just
keeping them alive is more than I can
manage well you can thank your corporate
overlords for that yes well we are doing
all we can if we can get this subway
train moving we can evacuate some
survivors but we need help my men cannot
do this alone
how is she suddenly okay now alright
sure she has a multiple broken bones
lying on their side
baby it's cool we all want the same
thing
Thank You Jill all right stop
okay so Carlos OPC has no idea I think
not she's doing contact I know what a
radio is stances first things first we
need to get you geared up head up to
street level you'll find supplies there
all right
wait I wouldn't say hi to the civilians
- yawns I want to shoot but I'm like I'm
not gonna waste my we read
in the demo and in demo that was an
average for resnickie was right just
pretty cool there's quite a few
you can read that if you want to pull
this video because I've already but this
is endemic working on it so what's the
plan
clearing the tracks and how do I do that
copy that
let's do this fast yeah yeah
wait how do I get up my inventories and
I okay um yes if job yeah but y'all so I
can make some more I'm a perfect
both in here
wait whoa
why would I oh right I need to unlock it
somehow I need this
Oh controls the map keep trying to
crunch with it
the map is useful for more than just
your current location it can also show
you points of interest blahblahblah
sweet so the only thing I'm worried
about using a PC for is that I might not
be able to sneak as easily and in
Resident Evil 2 that was very important
so we shall see oh yes
right
you want somebody kiss your boo-boo go
someplace else tell me about the haps
we know how to use this
let's put one of these in here
save the game did I save yeah I did
[Music]
gotta get that tree moving I do love the
level design the focus
oh cool oh cool oh cool out no no no no
this way this would W always present W
to go forward and she was to wait I was
what's mine maybe I was pressing yes I'm
an idiot
cool anyway let's stop dancing
one hit once wait switch to a gun we do
you fool
[ __ ] I forgot that you come out
wait why am i already doing okay
you might just take me a little while
just give me a second guys I need to
keep
when I get into this one tonight
oh hi already
please give me greenhouse
oh yeah the red barrels oh my god how
did I forget
Carlos I'd reached the main avenue which
way do I go see a big transmission tower
that's the substation you have to circle
around through an alley to your right to
get there
you mean the alley that's on the fire
baby sure we get a tall drink of water
like yourself
[Music]
we gotta be we gotta be clever and with
all this
you can't quite I'm just gonna
it's too many of them down there
it's anything to get down
no I don't think so okay I'm just I'm
just like leading them towards me which
ways take our last time because I want
to go the opposite way this time I think
I did I go up there I can't member do
they go this way I can't remember
I don't think I went up here
ah little mustache
yes
what the [ __ ] is that noise is
you can hear it but I can't see it
please don't wake up please don't wake
up please don't wake up please don't
wake up please don't wake up please
don't wake up
[Music]
No
get out the way the [ __ ] red berries
pick oh my god oh my god it's giving me
foot crowd
okay cool don't why we got some more
gunpowder
cool
what's down here Oh back down there
again I guess we can just drop it down
so if we ever need to quickly go back
around this way we can anything on here
what do we have here then
I need to find the coat the new hair
tonic come on brother is just fine I
remember reading this new safe is
perfect that a cure cream I remember
having comments like how did you miss
the equity or cream I was like I don't
so um let's see if I actually notice it
this time
thank you
feel safe
there you are [ __ ] knew you were
gonna be s somewhere die [ __ ] Oh
[ __ ] Al's gonna say these ones seem
to say dead don't you dare okay
I was proven wrong I need I need some
help oh my gosh I know
nothing down here nothing down here
let's just go
you hide it any good stuff
- IKEA speech junkie
ah
yeah okay as a pepper so was he not
hiding and it gets tough
I'm not finding any of those things that
I need to oh my god oh my god
thank you
all right we're hurt oh please I keep
trying keep dying keep dying oh my gosh
please give me a crane out I came all
the way oh my god yeah what whoa wasn't
even worth it though woman oh no no no
[ __ ] you
just don't come in here and I would be
happy oh my god
it's that green hat over the table oh my
god don't come in here don't come in
here no one's here no one's here
but where's this aqua cure [ __ ] thing
stay dead [ __ ] a quick cure there it is
that's why I didn't notice it although
he's a nice lady nine three seven nine
three seven remember that
left right left nine three seven please
remember that guys because I broke nine
three seven show credit in my hand
nine three wait pause okay we got it
oh it's nice I don't want to do this
because I haven't got the gun through
yeah
okay good this one's still down down and
out can we get in here
we're down there
will he stay
they did when they just randomly move
fast there's nothing a subway company's
offices
I need something to open all these boxes
and it's probably the same thing that
all opened the doors that a lot
similarly to that in the event of a
power outage who uh oh yes this is how
to start the train again okay so I need
to restore the power how I done that
yeah nothing yeah I haven't messed up
the power yet okay you still alive okay
this is what we need
Brandon's getting worse and worse these
past few days got a shotgun for when it
hits breaking point yes please give me
this shotgun I love shotguns we all know
I love shotguns please if you don't know
I love shotguns
hello shotguns cool looking it up in the
gun rack that should keep it safe how do
I get it I have to cut the chain and
bust out that stuck out I don't have
anything to cut it though
[ __ ] this is where it is isn't there oh
hang grenades okay well tell you what
should we just combine these so we can
at least get this hand grenade unless
there's something better yeah
like a green herb you know I'll take
this oh there's a shotgun hmm okay so I
don't know what's it now in anyway [ __ ]
[ __ ]
why
okay hey guys hey look at me over here
just come a little bit closer come
closer come hither I promise it will all
be okay
come on I'm waiting for that dude at the
back ah I love it
so simple
thank you needed
I remember this oh no I remember this we
all know what's gonna happen here but
I'm not going near that door because it
will trigger a cutscene that I think
more trigger nematocysts if this is the
same as the demo then we're screwed this
wasn't in the demo I'm not gonna lie I
can't play horror games without
live-streaming it to you cuz I got too
scared so thank you guys for allowing me
to still play one of my favorite genres
let's sort out this how am i doing on
the house oh nice I'm not doing too bad
I got four knives a lot of ammo we don't
destroy gun yeah it's like I put that in
there I can't wait to get my pocket
space
I wonder what we do with this hmm oh
wait
oh I don't like it
yeah let me one second
just get this gunpowder not gonna go
back to what's that done one thing I
don't like about this game is like when
you get caught well I keep going the
prompt to do a left click but apparently
I'm never quick enough even though I
swear I'm doing it but she doesn't seem
to be using her her knives or anything
one is grenade to his gun it's nothing
I'm sorry boys the night
Oh weird okay
we're okay
[Music]
where did we get those um clippers from
guys I can't remember the demo anymore
it's been too long
because I need those Clippers
is that what they're called Ben cutters
I need those big big scissors yeah
there's the big big scissors oh we've
got another save room right here Oh I'm
not starving your way I'm good tree bolt
cutters that's what they're cause oh we
need to go back to that safe as well
it's safe there
yeah we'll just run around I'm sure I'll
find it eventually so can I use my purse
bolt cutters on you
yes yeah careful careful
come on don't look at me like that all
right no he did not give any [ __ ] he
might have been infected killing your
own people he would have turned where's
your sense of self-preservation go back
to the subway station no way I've done
very well on my own so far thank you
very much
I'm sorry dude
suck at present the umbrella corporation
just recruited me for a job a job wait
we working in prison or were you in
prison don't know how they're gonna wipe
out a life sentence for murdering 20
gangbangers but whatever I'll take it oh
you're right in prison cool cool cool
beats [ __ ] away the rest of my day
behind bars I gotta get back in shape
target practice at 400 yards five misses
caught the chain yesterday and got moved
to a uvcs training camp where I fired my
first pilot in two whole years misses
stationary target but five inches at 400
yards I never [ __ ] do that it's like
I forgot everything doesn't matter I'll
get sharp again just watch me okay I got
my shot proving down to three inches
feeling good feeling good after lunch
they put me through my first mock battle
the cap and the other guys are good
people and goddamn beasts at war of war
at that beast said god of war but what
the [ __ ] is up with that lunatic Nikolai
he used me as a [ __ ] shield just to
score some extra points was that Nikolai
that just shot Sean Murphy's back baby
you will never see me miss another
target today yeah tomorrow I go my first
mission why I control a Raccoon City I
think Jimmy would have liked that my
brother was always the first to reach
out and help people right up until those
Punk's took him away from me now it's my
turn to do some good for a change the
way I know best
well at least that little notepad gave
you a little bit denture narc it's quite
nice for you isn't it okay
we're getting more shotgun shells
and the world mices like I want to see
someone else suffer nemesis because I've
just played it
cuckoo cuckoo I wonder how I all this is
so cute I love the freakin details of
the levels and Resident Evil they're
just it's very good
that's why it has been
this
public use generators provided by Oasis
women ET girl g-shot ongoing power
outages the dark the gills has decided
to professionally place a number of
electric generators in city everyone is
welcome to use them but remember these
generators are running high voltage
circuits if one were to be struck or
impacted by gunfire oh I've already done
this you got that if you see a generator
spreading sparks don't go near it
don't do anything stupid safety first as
the saying goes as the saying goes if we
make it through this mess I'll have
plenty of busted generators for sale the
bargain prices well I don't think that's
gonna happen but it will help me with
our little zombie infestation so thank
you
yeah yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] I did it oh so
premature I don't think the talks
chasing me anymore
famous last words
okay
no no no no the dogs still chasing me go
go go go go just like this
no Jesus Christ Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ can get you the dog you do the
dog can see the doggy through this door
it's all dolls okay great just bad
I guess I can still I'm not paper enough
oh my god
they're everywhere [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Joey
Joey Joey Joey Joey Joey can I just
combined it combined it without like
having to oh thank you that's that's
just really helpful
oh god no you're big you're big you
[ __ ] don't kill me please
Morty oh my god just go please
[Music]
no verbs yeah oh my god I hate these
people why are you my being annihilated
just just go
just just go just go just go this is
going to have up here though sweet right
yeah that's that's it I like this thank
you
I really sucked just then I can't do
that again I've got to pick up oh my
gosh thank you I'm sorry dill look at
you you had so much pain I'm sorry I
know I'm the worst
I miss once the violent outbreaks across
the city we've implemented an
international intentional power outage
once the situation has been brought
under control please activate the fault
breakers ASAP once that's done turn on
the main power switch in a control room
to reactivate the power grid okay
I feel like I should heal but I'm only
on caution something bad do have two
green halves in here I could take one
out maybe just use that one
what the hell ah
we gonna meet some new tight one
smashing and guessing oh my gosh we did
not need to take that one with us look
I'm gonna go put it back
my child was never gonna come back from
this round so I put my head in there and
[ __ ] me
next thing I know I've got some kind of
maggots squirming down my throat I was
gagging and heaving with us on buses and
it seemed to mind none they just
wouldn't come up I was standing around
like a madman and then I saw it at green
hearth my grandma once told me that grim
hubs are a natural bug deterrent so I
grabbed one shoved at demagogue and
swallowed and what do you know the
little things didn't want to be in there
anymore I've never been so happy to
throw up I'm gonna head back out there
to look for chart if anyone else sees
this to remember eat your greens greens
guys keeps you healthy combined to these
a GT
the key to the high voltage area has
gone missing and the earliest we'll be
able to get a replacement is next week
in the interim a lockpick can be
provided yes please there's so many of
these doors that need to open we only
have one lockpick and can't afford to
lose it so please keep it it in its
carrying case at all times when you're
not using it and please could you all
check just one more once more that you
haven't accidentally taken the key home
okay so we can have some disgusting
maggots trying to get down our oh he's
holding something
he's gonna he's gonna wake up even
though we just shot them in the head and
nothing happens my gates don't let them
get into you
this is the lockpick yes mmm
I think I'm gonna go back and put one of
these safe
we just got I don't want to say oh yes
there's nice and nice nice
I don't know why okay wait I hurt myself
[ __ ] just I didn't mean to do that
come on cannot be safe in here I know I
know I missed the generator okay I'm
just trying to find a safe spot
then shooting from up here
where is it again
it's
ah I want to stay up here I can save
I need to go back down I birdie oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh nice I'm gonna die I'm gonna die guys
I'm gonna die [ __ ] okay I need to go
back
they're not that hard skill okay wait
let's go let's go back what happened to
this place I've seen some strange [ __ ]
when past few days those strange bugs
building the nest that metallic smell
wafting to the bench [ __ ] if it didn't
all go so it's a hell of a night I need
just checking in on my mark town but the
boss says I can't leave till I drop all
the breakers god dammit better finish up
quick so I can get out of here
[ __ ] me my stomach hurts oh but much I
can hardly move at the last breaker a
big ugly possible bug got the drop on me
and shoved a big [ __ ] tube down my
throat I managed to get away and somehow
kept from vomiting this spot [ __ ]
hurts feels like something's moving
inside holding it together can't believe
I believe have a cute
I love you mama oh that's so cute
okay don't don't forget there's
something down here somebody's kill it
oh hello there it is okay with wicked
give me up get me up get me up to me on
I should have kept all of those green
herbs with me oh my god why am I going
back down
I need to get more greenhouse why did I
do this room
because I already did this one
no I already did that one die [ __ ]
I'm gonna check the ceilings
I can hear it [ __ ] yeah
oh my god huh okay I don't want to turn
around and scared huh why am i hugging
it okay no don't you dare
don't look up go look up cannot walk
underneath one I have no green herbs
I can't guys to shoot chipper I can take
those anymore
where is the last one
I'm lost
what okay
Wow
why am i wheezing Oh
another one
how do I get over there
here not stop hugging it
[Music]
too much going on too much going on I'm
pressing caps look into [ __ ]
[ __ ] your shirt I need to find how to
get out of here or at least up oh my god
this is out Jesus Christ that was so
intense
no I man okay all that these are the
main power switch
well done Jill you didn't use a good
girl
you did good enjoy oh thank god
[Music]
how are you doing oh you know you even
do not bad
oh that was quite something should we
take one or not I feel like we should
just wait
apparently the beasts says there's no
more bugs oh thank god I'm actually
right I think I know the building
well there's some peas going hell yeah
oh thank you I used so much ammo down
there uh-huh
I already appreciate that you again you
know just what I need
you are the one who taketh away I
suppose right please don't say that I'm
gonna run into more dogs you know just
walk up this ramp come on come on girl
oh I have my car Nadeau yeah oh is this
dead-end I hope
oh this what's it gonna mow No
whoa
did you see that it's like a trap back
in the cypher please get back in Sigma
place oh my gosh okay at least for the
safe room oh yeah it's first first eight
straight up the game nice makes you feel
good but I'm gonna save it
Bryan's set the I missed a case the
nemesis drops but I don't really fancy
going back there do I have to
was that something really good well I
guess I've saved now so
Oh
this actually it makes everything tense
up it's so
Oh 3-shot still ahead is what you need
to do to get them down just for a little
bit they do a mistake
okay thank you for letting me know about
this I wouldn't have gone back to get it
out yeah nice this safe is up that way I
have the code for it now but nemesis is
here so maybe we can outrun him unless
this we're in this safe room there's a
safe room here
okay we'll just go outside see what
happens hey zombies
[ __ ]
oh there's no zombies here
Oh oh yeah
uh-oh what my doing well supposed to go
to the same room I can't believe I just
totally didn't get rid to the same room
no oh no no no no no no no no no [ __ ] it
then nothing happens I didn't get anyone
[Music]
I might have to redo this bit wait let's
just get this while we're here what is
this a shotgun shell yes bloody kidding
me okay let's go come on girl go back
into the doughnut shop let's try this
again go into the safe room this time
okay
save room
here we go oh it's just look like this
was that oh no can't even wait should we
use this oh let's just use that
nemesis can wait while we do this oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay how do we do
that
mm okay I'm gonna try and go out to the
right and then go to the left okay
he's not just like straight outside the
door
that's them right right yeah that's them
right right yeah oh my god
I never says find him since going oh
wait they got me did they get him I just
saw no no no no this way
was it this way wait but he's just gonna
follow me so how am I supposed to do
that only wait for me will I do this
safe I hope so well okay 97
sweet
our gun is come along our gun is coming
along perhaps I don't want to get out
the screen because I knew I've got
zombie to the left of me now I know I've
got nemesis behind me so it's hard
oh my gosh
she's not okay how are you doing okay
you already on coaching that's not too
bad here we go here we go
but wait no no no this is not where I
want to go I've forgotten where like
everything in
oh my god oh cool
corner mean I hate you I hate you I hate
you I hate you ain't your haze right
shotgun
home with ammo though just imagined
y'all being like yo chill dude let me
give them let me crack this thing's
first and he's like yeah sure why not
oh my god Christ a spray you are the
best okay sweetie it does come with mine
I feel like he's just constantly that
was in control ways now what okay give
me a second
all right where are we headed patrina
stopped at Redstone Street we need to
reach Fox Fox station
okay they'll auxilary puzzle consider it
done
Fox bug how do we do this
ar e
oh it's like how they're going to get so
what are these will stand for we f/a
know we've beyond but that's for oh okay
good so we'd be on three here and then
we get to synched Michael clock tower si
I guess and that would be number four
unable to establish with wait try it yet
si O 2 si O 2 okay
valid route confirmed no Carlos it's me
I finished in hitting a subway route
so his name's to write back to the
station
make sure the subways ready to depart
mmm doughnuts oh my gosh I finally found
one I'm Way more in the dinner
nice can I put them straight in the gun
[ __ ]
no I can't even
swapping with anything oh well oh well
we have gun shotgun shells
wait-wait-wait
oh my god open your eyes
no wha what's waiting for you to open
okay we need to make our way back to the
subway station out here to the donut
shop we got this we can do this
right do leg shorts work let's try this
out
oh it's [ __ ] - hell yeah - the
I don't think I need these for anything
else you might need the lockpick for
something though
though here time right we should know
away from that
let's do this
great keep the boat Cup sake why ah
what do I need the book cut the for but
I'm already going to the other safe
point so I could get out there I'm fine
I don't know what sir
I don't think I made a difference today
oh it did hell yeah
he's
[Music]
oh my god this is why I need the bunkers
thank you so much I think it was someone
on the back if it wasn't and thank you
so much for who told me to we're going
in yet Oh Spain yes mom
I don't want this I want a green hat oh
yes oh that's perfect
I don't need them anymore okay so I need
to start you
mom Jill turn around
ain't got no time for your nonsense oh
no this place is so cool I wish I could
actually enjoy it the original Charlie
doll was based on the likeness of toy
uncle's founder Charlie McGowan and has
become the mascot for the company we're
pleased to present this porcelain
Charlie doll as a celebration of our
25th anniversary this is the nice little
break from running away from nemesis
isn't it yeah he dropped a case again
again individually crafted with love and
care by our staff this limited edition
item makes for a precious gift we hope
he'll find his place as the cherished
member of your family
this product is extremely fragile make
sure not to strike it I don't does he
not come in here Hey look at him
asserting his dominance on that poor
little zombie down there it's actually
quite scary is he looking at me
nice-looking that something I think
we're stunning this yeah that's a good
mmm I guess I could use one of these I
don't really want to though like could
this anyway
Jane loads of these mommy cool
I know party he dropped something but I
really don't want to go get it so I have
to get it guys
leave is is like run but I gotta get the
buns lady drop did he drop it just out
here where is it I can't see it I can't
see a box back in the donut shop is that
where he dropped it oh my gosh it is
look it supply case we have to we have
to do now don't mean
are you all ready for this Joe they're
making me do it
don't don't play me like we have come on
Jill don't die don't die she's a naughty
good shape
why did I do that he's behind us not in
front of us
where is it there it is oh no I had this
space for us like nothing okay thank God
this handgun is getting afraid so much
these were in good shape you can put
this away now
all the way back
all right
I know I know you hate me is okay
Jill turn the [ __ ] around you little
[ __ ] no does not hurt him whatsoever
does it [ __ ] there's to me sandy No
please Irina
am I going the right way
ha ha what am i doing and I'm scared
right
no just where right now but it's down
there
thank you for the big sign just go oh my
gosh that was way too much I am in such
pain right now what do we have so I have
any greenhouse okay I've got one Green
having ham
dangerous we need to find more green
herbs please
still yet so yeah oh it almost looks
like I could get this working if I plug
in the right whatever it is I have an
idea but I I think I'm missing just one
that's why annoying
yeah oh wait no this three oh yeah I am
so glad I picked up all that stuff I
mean it would have been nice if I had
green herb too but I guess beggars can't
be choosers sweets okay and I am going
to call it there call it a day
thanks for watching guys I'm gonna chill
out now and play some animal crossing to
calm down we're all hot I'm not you can
say goodbye now so have a lovely day or
evening
bye to anyone who I haven't managed to
say goodbye to you that's in the chat
and also goodbye to anyone who might not
be in the chat but has been watching I
appreciate it as always have a good
evening and stay safe talk to you next
time cool okay have a lovely bye